you
the world today 2008 it's trying to
overcome American dominance in the world
trying to overcome the American military
bullying that's taking place here and
there in the world in Iraq in
Afghanistan and you know military bases
in a hundred countries and I think
people are trying to work their way
towards a more democratic society
wherever possible it and to do it
without war and and I think this
movement towards a more democratic
societies societies more concerned with
human rights oh we've already seen it
begin to happen in Latin America with
movements from autocratic and elitist
States to more populous states and if
maybe the european union represents this
in some way and it's a long term process
but i think you know what is going on is
an attempt to create a world which is
different than the world of the past
hundred years which was a world of an
incessant war and domination of the
world by super powers first two
superpowers and now one superpower